the unemployment rate in the european
union has reached a high of nearly 12
percent
in some countries one in every four
workers does not have a job
this is a tough time for many people but
the eu
offers opportunities the eu single
market offers europeans the freedom to
move abroad for work
to take advantage for example of
vacancies where employers cannot find a
local candidate
would you be open to living and working
elsewhere in europe tell us what would
encourage you or put you off
and what about europe's young people are
you aware of eu support from student
exchange programs and internships
to training courses and funding for
entrepreneurs but what else could we be
doing
unemployment does the eu need to take
other actions
and what should we leave to national
governments and how can the eu help to
boost small and medium-sized enterprises
the backbone of europe's economy what
action could we take to help these
companies grow
if you've got something to say we want
to hear it join the great jobs online
debate between 23rd and 25th september
and share your views with eu politicians
and your european neighbours
it really could help shape what happens
next
you